kelsey gabbard knows this very well
she's a former member of congress from
hawaii she knows rogan very well and we
thought it'd be interesting to hear her
take on all of this
we'll see gabriel thanks so much for
joining us tonight so you're watching
and you know god knows i should probably
should have added this to the script but
you know we don't know where this is
going i it's hard to imagine they're
going to pull joe rogan off the air but
you know again you don't know once the
ball starts rolling
what do you make of the attempts to
censor joe rogan
it is yet the latest indicator about the
real danger that we're facing as a
society right now in this country is
that this fundamental freedom guaranteed
to every one of us as americans this
freedom of speech is being threatened
people are being intimidated their
financial security is being threatened
they are being censored or being
intimidated into censoring themselves
this freedom is is the fabric of our
constitution and the fact that uh this
is what we're facing at the powers that
be decide well if you don't if we don't
like the things that you're saying then
we will find a way to silence you
and censor you this is something that
that every single american should be
afraid of because we need to have the
confidence in america that we can
express ourselves that we have the
freedom to speak without the threat of
punishment looming over us that right
there is literally the difference
between living in a democracy or living
in a dictatorship
i think that's exactly right and for the
white house press secretary
to call for censorship from the podium
in the white house briefing room is real
i've never seen anything like that ever
and i'm 52. let me ask i think this is
revealing this why i thought it was
worth talking about joe rogan's not a
right winger it's not like they can say
oh he's a scary q anon character he's
certainly not he seems pretty apolitical
pretty much a centrist they simply hate
him because he asks obvious questions or
am i missing something
uh
you're not missing something you know
he's he is someone who who's curious he
encourages dialogue of course he's got
his own opinions about thing but he
can't be put in a box and he can't be
controlled
again he is one example unfortunately
he's not the only example there are many
others who have experienced the brunt of
this punishment uh who are either being
attempted to be silenced or censored or
who have been and this this goes to a
bigger point here tucker that we're
facing right now with the prospect of a
supreme court vacancy the qualification
of a supreme court justice the foremost
and most important quality must be
someone who is committed to upholding
our constitution who is committed to
upholding the freedoms we are guaranteed
in that constitution freedom of speech
civil liberties and so on
not being chosen based on their gender
their sex their race or even their
politics we need to be looking for a
supreme court justice who is committed
and has a
track record of upholding our
constitution that's it
i i always laugh when you say things
like that because i was wondering why
why do you hate chelsea gabbard so much
because like joe rogan you're a threat
because you defend the essential
the ancient american values that the
country was based on you do it in a very
reasonable way that's nonpartisan and
that's the threat and so i appreciate
you doing that once again on our show
thank you tulsi gabbard
thanks hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else